Here's a no-bulk seam that
can be used anytime you're
joining stitches to stitches.
It was suggested by fellow knitter,
Maryanne, who was knitting for a child,
and she didn't want any bulk at the
shoulder of the sweater she was knitting.
Knit the last row of your
knitting at a very loose tension.
In this example, I knit the
swatch at tension 5and I  knit
the last row at tension 10.
That isn't always possible.
So try taking the tension off your working
yarn and knitting as loosely as possible.
If your garment tension is at the high
end of your tension dial, hand knit this
last row, loosely, not sloppy but loose.
You'll see why in a minute, then
scrap off with a contrasting color.
To make things easier
and set the stitches,
go ahead and steam your knitting.
I chose to work from the purl
side so I folded that waste yarn
under, so the purl bumps of the
last row on each edge are clear.
Keep the waste yarn in place for now.
Starting at whichever side
is comfortable for you.
Use your latch tool, pick up one
loop from the front piece and
put that loop behind the latch.
Pick up the first loop of the back piece
and leave it in the hook of your latch
tool and pull it through, put that loop
behind the latch and pick up a new loop
from the front piece and pull it through.
Strand behind the latch, pick up a loop
from the back piece and pull it through.
In other words, you're alternating,
pulling loop through loop, back
to front, front, to back working
every stitch across the row.
When you're all the way across
the knitting, use the tail
to secure that last loop.
This produces a no-bump seam and a
decorative chain joining the seam.
I hope you'll give this one a try.
Not only does it reduce the bulk, but
it provides a more stable seam than
joining by weaving with Kitchener stitch.